hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie we're on the paramount back lot
filming the opening sequence of jackass
forever
we brought in a number of new cast
members i want to say my name all right
is zach i'm jasper and this is body surf
your mother
this is my first movie
[Music]
it was really great to be invited into
the crew and everything
what'd you think when you got the call
to come in and sit down with us first
thought was hopefully i don't die
then i was like hey at least i'll die on
camera
how you doing over there rachel hey man
go into space
they made me laugh so hard and i'm
literally seeing childhood heroes of
mine like come to life
grandpa are you okay my mind is blunt
i'm eric i'm from south london i love
skating and i love getting a bit
hurt when you get knocked down i'm
poopies
big time movie star
my friend tripp goes hey i want to
introduce you to a couple of my friends
i want you to come test out for jackass
and i was like no way like speechless at
that moment it's a texas rat snake
venomous
[Applause]
but you love snakes no i don't you don't
love snakes no
i was pretty nervous getting brought
into this movie honestly because i'm
doing like crazy stuff with all these
people that i've looked up to my entire
life
check those guys are getting old we paid
our dues so we're handing the torch to
you
i love this dude the new people that
we're working with are great and we've
been destroying them throughout this
film
did you guys feel like you had to earn
it with the guys
for sure
i was so nervous but yeah it was a dream
come true that's the best part it's like
yeah i'm afraid of doing this
[Music]
it's gonna look awesome
you